[Music]
hey guys i'm kelly and today jasmine has
challenged me to make all of my meals
for the day in a mug in the microwave in
the restaurant world we call this bad
boy chef mike and he's definitely not
getting any michelin stars so i'm a
little iffy about it and at the end
jasmine is going to give me a yay or an
a let's see if we can whip up some
gourmet meals that jasmine likes all
right first up is breakfast i don't know
about you but i definitely didn't eat
anything this fancy in college it was
bagel maybe toast but today i am making
a ricotta blueberry mug cake it's
basically like a fancy pancake in a bowl
so we have some ricotta some maple syrup
butter because it makes everything
better
yeah it does milk i'm actually using oat
milk today because i'm making it for
jasmine and i know she loves oat milk
she's gonna whisk that
so this is a little challenging trying
to whisk and make sure it's all combined
in this tiny little mug
this is a no-no in culinary world you
need to have a bigger bowl so you can
get in there i actually have a hack for
this one i do this i just go oh
jasmine is telling me to go like this
and she's right
this is perfect okay now we're gonna add
our dry we just have some flour
baking powder
and salt always add salt i feel like i
say that in every video but
i love salt and it makes your food
better so this is like an upgraded fancy
pancake for jasmine because i've added
ricotta which is going to give it like a
little bit of a tang and also make it
super tender now i'm going to fold in
some blueberries
and that's it
you're definitely going to want to cover
all the meals we're making today so it
doesn't explode in your microwave and
make a huge mess if you're not
comfortable with saran wrap just put a
plate on top just cover it trust it
all right so i'm going to cook it for
three minutes check it and then if it
needs more time i'll just add one more
minute
so just a heads up your cook time will
differ depending on how powerful your
microwave is so just keep checking in to
see where it's at
to make my streusel topping i'm going to
add some flour brown sugar
just toss that together a little pinch
of cinnamon
and then some cubed butter
make sure it's cold because i'm really
trying to impress jasmine so i am making
a brown sugar crumble everything should
be evenly combined and looks like one
cohesive mask instead of like bits of
flour bits of butter so i'm just gonna
put some on top i'm gonna cover it one
more time it's back in the microwave for
another minute and a half
all right let's see if chef mike failed
me or
no
oh
oh i don't think i should have put the
saran wrap on the second time because
it's like trapping moisture in and it's
just
it's not a crumble shove mic has failed
me but i'm gonna put it back in the
microwave and see if i can get those
bits a little crunchier all right i just
checked on it it's definitely working
but i'm gonna give it 30 more seconds
all right
honestly it doesn't look that great but
i can smell it and i think it's gonna
taste great all right so to garnish this
i'm just gonna add some fresh
blueberries
i know jasmine hates warm fruit so i'm
hoping these cold blueberries will help
balance out everything and she'll love
it and to finish i'm just gonna garnish
with a little powdered sugar
i'm still not satisfied with the look so
i went and grabbed a little mint so cute
just adds a pop of color all right let's
bring jasmine in and see if she gives
this ricotta blueberry cake a yay or an
a all right you ready try it yes all
right here you go thank you
i love
yay
whenever i think mug meal i think mac
and cheese lasagna pizza and a mug no
one ever thinks blueberry ricotta mug
cake what do you think of the ricotta so
creamy and you get that little bit of
tang
this is a jasmine yay you know lunch is
coming up soon all right all right time
to get to work get out of here let's go
i'm taking yourself
next up for lunch i'm making jasmine a
thai curry noodle soup it is not the
most authentic but i think it will give
you that curry fix you're looking for
we're starting off with some thai red
curry paste and add coconut milk water
soy sauce fish sauce and then just like
a little pinch of sugar to balance out
all those flavors
then i've just julienned some snow peas
just to one add your veggies and give it
a little bit of crunch then i've broken
up some rice noodles in half i'm just
gonna stick them in there now on to the
shrimp we are starting with frozen raw
shrimp and this is so it doesn't
overcook in the microwave if you're a
little worried about microwaving shrimp
just make sure that it is opaque
throughout and not translucent i forgot
to add my
aromatics so we are just going to add a
little bit of ginger powder and garlic
powder we know jasmine loves garlic so
i'm gonna cover it with a plate
and then pop it in the microwave for
three and a half minutes
[Music]
all right
it smells so good that's what's expected
look at that
my shrimp are cooked the vegetables
stayed green
that's really surprising the noodles
look tender
if you take it out and your noodles are
still a little bit crunchy just pop it
back in the microwave for like another
minute or two because you really want
them to be al dente and not raw to add a
little pizzazz we're just going to
garnish it with fresh
cilantro i can't wait for her to try
this it smells so good let's see if she
likes it all right here's your lunch
thank you
oh my goodness you know i love a good
nude
no
i didn't know you love a good nude no
cheers mmm
would you ever know that's something
microwave
never
cooked through all dented like it's like
perfect big yay from me two years so far
now i'm gonna make you dinner thank you
so much
i'm so excited about this one we're
making risotto in the microwave we're
adding mushrooms we're adding thyme it's
going to be so delicious
so we just got some butter
and onions we are going to saute our
onions for just about 60 seconds in the
microwave to get the cooking process
started and soften them up the butter's
melted
they look a little bit softened
exactly what we want i'm going to add
some garlic
our mushrooms
some thyme
you can use fresh or dried doesn't
matter arborio rice
a little bit of white wine
a little excited about the white wine
don't worry about the alcohol it's going
to cook off but you can just leave it
out if you don't want it and then a
little bit of chicken stock you can also
use veggie broth whatever you like all
right so i'm going to put this in the
microwave covered for eight minutes
stirring every 90 seconds just to make
sure it doesn't bubble over
wow the rice is fluffy it's cooked
through
all right the last step is to just add
some parmesan and parmesan is super
salty so
this will really add a ton of flavor to
your dish i'm gonna go a little simple
here with the garnish just a little bit
of cracked black pepper so i think it
really pairs well with the creaminess of
the parmesan
that's it let's go see if she likes it
all right dinner time
i think this is going to be your
favorite
okay oh my god i love risotto i can't
believe you even made for someone in a
microwave i know
i told you
moment of silence
you were
unreal the mushroom is so rich the rice
is cooked to perfection yay or nay yay
three yay baby
that is three days it's time for dessert
okay last up is dessert i know it is
jasmine's favorite meal of the day so
i'm making a snickerdoodle mug cake so
we're gonna start with some flour
brown sugar
salt
baking powder
just gonna stir this
then we're gonna add some water
melted butter a little vanilla and
lastly a little cinnamon because what is
snickerdoodle without cinnamon just a
sugar cookie
sugar that's a sad sugar cookie so i'm
mixing the batter first in a bowl
because i'm going to layer this batter
in my mug with layers of cinnamon and
sugar in between is it worth my time i
don't know we'll see so i'm just going
to pour a little bit in here
add a sprinkle of cinnamon sugar
all right some more batter
more sugar batter
do a little bit more sugar all right i'm
gonna pop this in the microwave for a
minute and a half
it smells like cinnamon sugar heaven in
here like oh my god and just to really
make this special for jasmine i'm gonna
add some vanilla ice cream
all right we're gonna add some caramel
drizzle and
dark chocolate chips let's get her in
and have some desserts
dessert thank you
this is beautiful i just can't believe
everything you made today is from a
microwave so i did well
well you did perfect yay how many
jasmine stars do you give chef mike four
four
one star for every mug meal you can make
gourmet meals in the microwave you
really can thank you guys for watching
let us know in the comments which one
was your favorite bye all of them oh yes
[Music]
you